[Music]
in total publicly traded US tech
companies have stashed as much as five
hundred thirty billion in offshore tax
havens money that the US government may
never see fan-favorite Microsoft
operates five shell companies that hold
nearly 93 billion in profit that's
twenty nine point six billion in tax
revenue up in smoke they've used some of
that tax-free profit to buy foreign
companies like Nokia and most recently
they burnt 2.5 billion to buy minecraft
creator Mojang Oracle operates six shell
companies where they pay a measly four
percent tax on their thirty nine billion
stash and Google is operated as many as
twenty five shell companies and tax
havens since no US taxes get paid on
their forty seven point four billion
dollar hoard these dollars truly become
Google bucks make me want to vomit well
it gets worse
in 2011 Dells Dutch subsidiary did a
1/10 of 1% tax on two billion in profit
the kicker the shell company had zero
employees finally famous watchmaker
Apple has three Irish subsidiaries for
tax purposes as of 2013
two of these companies had zero
employees yet altogether they hold 69
point 7 billion in profits which is 24
billion in taxes yep you guessed it
never paid given these strategies apples
overall tax rate just keeps following
from 24.8% in 2009 to fourteen point
seven percent 2010 to nine point eight
percent in 2011 meanwhile it's become
the world's most valuable company so
this year when you're sacrificing your
paycheck to pay your taxes just think
about all the ways you could turn that
money back into profit if you are a big
giant company
and if you want more wired videos just
click subscribe it's good